hi it's Michelle of lab muffin Beauty
science chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist
and today we're doing something a little
bit different I recently saw this list
of top products mentioned on the
skincare addiction subreddit on Reddit I
don't know how many people know this but
I actually used to be a moderator there
from 2014 till 2019 so I'm really
familiar with these products and I
thought it would be interesting to do
like a tier ranking list which I've seen
Anthony fantano and James Welsh and tons
of other people do we're going to go
through reddit's top 15 products and put
them onto this tier which goes from Holy
Grail all the way down to not for anyone
and then below that I've got like a
little area which is products that I
haven't actually tried as usual these
are my opinions on the products my skin
is not your skin don't stop using a
product you love because I didn't like
it so this list of most discussed
products on skincare addiction it's from
a site called luria and it's from the
last year so the mentions can be good or
bad it's not really distinguished so I
would expect most of them are good
mentions though okay so our first
product is the CeraVe hydrating cleanser
and this is pretty much no surprise
CeraVe is like reddit's favorite
skincare brand it makes sense it fits in
with a lot of needs of the people from
the skincare addiction demographic so
from a 2017 survey I don't think there's
a newer one most of the people on there
are female which is the case with pretty
much anything skincare but also in their
20s so Sarah these products are very
budget friendly Reddit is a largely
us-based site and CeraVe is really easy
to get pretty much anywhere in the US
lots of people end up on skincare
addiction because they're looking for
solutions to their acne and this is
recommended by tons of dermatologists
for that because it's really it's
suitable for such a wide range of people
it's fragrance free they're very
inoffensive formulas Reddit users are
generally more focused on effectiveness
of skin care products rather than
enjoyment most people got there to try
to fix a problem with their skin Reddit
is also a text-based site and so there's
a lot more info is on information rather
than anything aesthetic like something
like Instagram or Tick Tock I think
they're fine they're a very safe
recommendation if you're looking for
plain products but I do kind of just
find them a little bit boring a bit
joyless I prefer a more sensory
experience with my skincare I like
things that feel nice and smell nice so
yeah they're good but I find it
difficult to actually get excited about
them so the hydrating cleanser I think
one of the reasons it is so popular is
because it is non-foaming so there is
this very popular myth that foaming
cleansers dehydrate your skin and this
has been around for ages and it still
persists I've talked about this before
in my video about cleanser myths more
foam doesn't necessarily mean less
gentle and more stripping there are lots
of ways to boost foam in a cleanser
without just turning to harsh
surfactants back in the day I think this
was more of an issue because the only
real way that people made cleanser's
foam was by adding more sodium lauryl
sulfate which tends to be drying unless
it's formulated carefully so I think
this myth is still around because of
more old school skincare experts and
also just like Legacy information online
so this is a good cleanser it is really
hydrating the name CeraVe actually comes
from ceramise and multivasicular
technology and both of these are about
moisturizing ceramides are substances in
your skin that contribute to that Skin
Barrier and CeraVe products contain them
to replenish anything that's lost so
it's meant to restore them for more
moisturized less dry skin the
multiversicular technology part is about
having moisturizing ingredients in
little packages with multiple layers
around them and so that means that these
vesicles sit on your skin and slowly
release the moisturizing ingredients
over time so you have prolonged
moisturizing after you've used a CeraVe
product now I don't know how much of
this technology is going to last after
you've washed the cleanser off but it
does have a lot of hydrating ingredients
which at least will keep your skin
hydrated when you're cleansing which is
one of the more compromising steps in a
skincare routine when your skin becomes
a bit more vulnerable this cleanser is
not my favorite of their range it it is
a fatty alcohol-based formula that comes
out a bit like a kind of gel it doesn't
foam and I do have a preference for
foaming cleansers I just prefer how nice
they are to spread over my face I do
like the pump and I like that pretty
much all CeraVe cleansers come in pumps
I think this is also popular because it
is cerave's recommendation for dry skin
a lot of people on skincare addiction
again end up there because they have
acne and so many acne treatments are
quite drying so there's things like row
Accutane which is the oral drug which
dries out your skin quite a lot people
are maybe using tretinoin or adapling or
different or even benzoyl peroxide and
all of these will dry out your skin and
so you kind of want a cleanser that
isn't going to strip more I have oily
skin and so cerave's recommendation is
different so I was always bound to not
like this one as much but it is really
solid for people with dry skin so I'm
going to put it in solid Choice all
right the next product is the CeraVe
moisturizing cream so this is called the
CeraVe in the tub on Reddit yes CeraVe
have a lot of moisturizers in their
range and a lot of them have very
similar names and similar color coding
again this is for dry skin and with the
skincare addiction demographic it makes
sense that this is so popular this
folder hasn't changed much since CeraVe
started I think the biggest change was
that they took out parabens around 2020
for marketing reasons every once in a
while people will freak out about
parabens and then discover that the
CeraVe that their dermatologist
recommended is full of poison this is
not true I have a video on why clean
beauty is BS but it happens all the time
and I think it is happening on Tick Tock
probably right now so it makes sense
from a commercial angle to get rid of
parabens I guess as much as I hate it
because parabens are really safe
preservatives this has a really nice mix
of moisturizing ingredients there's my
favorite glycerin there's things like
petrolatum and dimethicone which are
occlusives they help seal in moisture so
you have the ceramides you have phytos
fingerstein which is an ingredient that
is mentioned make what's already in your
skin there's cholesterol which again is
already in your skin now there is this
problem with this product which is
closed comadones some people just get
tons of these with it close comadones
are like little uninflamed pimples so
you can squeeze out white stuff but it
doesn't go red a lot of the time we call
these clogged pores and a lot of people
put this down to the fatty alcohols in
the product I'm not sure if that is the
case it's the sateral alcohol but yeah
it does seem to be a problem so I'm
going to put this again in solid choice
because I think it is a good
recommendation for most people even if
it's not super suitable for my skin
which is more on the oily side okay on
to product three which is the CeraVe
foaming cleanser this one is my
preferred CeraVe cleanser it's good for
oily skin it is quite hydrating so it
turns out there are a couple of
different versions of this the one I
tried I bought in an Australian store so
that is the Australian and European
version which has cocoa beating as the
first surfactant there is a different
version which is sold in the US and you
K and that has cocometopropyl hydroxy
Saltine as the first surfactant I
haven't tried that one yet I'll have to
try to track it down the one I'm
reviewing here is the cocoa betaine I
was feeling pretty silly about not
noticing this earlier but then I saw
that the official Australian CeraVe
website got confused it has us reviews
on it so I stopped feeling bad it's got
a nice mix of ingredients so it's got
some really gentle surfactants that
aren't really harsh or stripping it's
called cocoa betaine it's got sodium
cocoa glycinate both of these are really
quite hydrating surfactants we also have
the standard moisturizing ingredients
that CeraVe puts in pretty much all of
their products so glycerin ceramides
hyaluronic acid I'm going to put this in
solid Choice the reason is I don't like
the way it smells and you know how some
things smell like chemicals which I hate
saying because I am a chemist but that
is what it smells like it's like really
artificial slightly plasticky smell I do
like it it's just going to be bumped
down to solid choice but because I don't
love it then we have a couple of other
CeraVe products we've got the CeraVe
daily moisturizing lotion and we have
the CeraVe PM facial moisturizing I
haven't tried either of these so I'm
going to put these down in no opinion
but to be honest I think they would
probably be pretty safe in solid Choice
the next product is the Paula's Choice
BHA liquid so this is the two percent
salicylic acid and I don't think this is
any surprise but it is going straight up
in the Holy Grails for me because this
product I have been using it since 2009
I've not stopped using it since then
this is like a legacy coal product that
has been popular since before 2009 the
reason I bought it was because I saw so
many rave reviews of it on the internet
back then and I think back then the
biggest influence was probably makeup
alley this is just a really good salsa
like as a product so if you have large
pores blackheads oily skin acne this is
probably going to help your skin I have
tried so many products on the market and
I still haven't found a salicylic acid
product that works as well as this on my
skin this is probably a bit less budget
friendly than your standard skincare
addiction product but if you look at it
per meal it's actually really good value
because this bottle just does not run
out the Polish Choice brand philosophy
matches really well with skincare
addiction there's a lot of emphasis on
science maybe some studies are taken a
bit too seriously but Paul was such a
Pioneer in educating consumers about
skin care and these products are just
really really good next we have the
ordinary's niacinamide and this is again
another really skincare addiction
friendly Brand This is actually I think
the ordinary's top seller as well the
whole brand is really budget friendly
and they really appeal to that sort of
person who cares about ingredients I
think they were also really important in
getting people to care about the science
behind skincare products because they
have these really technical names front
and center this product tends to be good
for people who have acne so again it
matches well with the skin care
addiction demographic but it does tend
to break some some people out and some
people become scared of niacinamide
because of this I would definitely
recommend trying more products with
niacinamide and not dismissing all
products with niacinamide on the basis
of this because I did that and then I
realized my skin actually loves
niacinamide it just doesn't love this
product it wasn't bad it was just you
know meh so I think this one I'm kind of
hovering between solid choice and that
because I think it doesn't work for a
big enough proportion of people
I'm gonna put it in meh for now the next
one is the CeraVe salicylic acid
cleanser I think this is a good product
for people whose skin maybe can't quite
tolerate salicylic acid maybe they're
using too many irritating ingredients
already if you're using these acne
products if you're using different or
tretinoin or if you're also using
benzoyl peroxide then maybe your skin is
a bit too irritated to go for something
like the poreless choice two percent BHA
you can just get a little bit of
salicylic acid and not dry out your skin
too much as a cleanser I think it is too
drying for everyday use even on my skin
which is more oily it did feel quite
dehydrating it also does smell a bit and
on my skin I didn't find that it did
very much and I think that's just
because I use so much of the Portland's
Choice two percent BHA there's only so
much that a salicylic acid cleanser can
add I'm going to put this on the solid
choice because I think it is a really
useful product for a lot of people
number nine is the Neutrogena Hydro
Boost water gel when Neutrogena came out
we with the Hydro Boost range it was
really exciting because there just
weren't many of these sort of Asian
textured moisturizers on the market what
I mean by Asian textured is that it's
got that sort of lightweight gel texture
that's really hydrating without feeling
heavy and this is just amazing for oily
skin now this product does have a little
bit of a stronger fragrance than I
prefer American Products in general tend
to be a bit more heavily fragranced than
Australian products and as far as I know
it doesn't come in fragrance free I'm
going to put this in solid Choice unless
of course you have a fragrance problem
next one is the cars RX Advanced now 96
mucin Power essence I'm actually kind of
surprised this is so high at the same
time I'm not that surprised because
skincare addiction's sister subreddit is
Asian beauty there's a lot of crossover
between users this has been a classic
for a really long time I think it was
launched maybe 2014-2015 and it has been
huge since then I've actually been
retrying this out properly for a video
that is coming out I think probably next
week my video schedule is super messed
up at the moment so that video is
actually already live so I'll save most
of my comments for that but this is a
really good product lots of people love
it some people do react to it but again
not that many so I'm gonna put this in
Holy Grail our next product is lavage
per se plus bomb this is going against
straight to the holy Grails this is my
Gosha product for whenever my skin is
really irritated this is a really thick
balm product that has lots of soothing
ingredients in it it's got B5 it's got
one of the centella derivatives Magic
Castle side it's just really good for
when your skin is irritated hated and
can't really handle much helps when I
have a lot of shaping around my nose for
example I'll just slather this on and go
to bed and the next day my skin will
just be a lot happier I don't think I've
ever finished a tube of this a little
does go a long way so I think it does
end up being pretty good Valley even
though La Roche passe is probably maybe
a little bit above CeraVe in terms of
budget our next product is the Cetaphil
gentle skin cleanser now this one is
interesting because the cleanser that
Cetaphil had before this new version was
actually like a product that everyone
kind of hated the old version had a
really short ingredients list which is
good if you have sensitive skin you
don't have to look through as many
ingredients to try to work out if you
can or can't use that product but it
just had a lot of ingredients that got
demonized so it had sodium lauryl
sulfate which is a surfactant that tends
to be a bit harsher it has fatty
alcohols which some people think break
them out it had propylene glycol which
sounds a lot like ethylene glycol which
is antifreeze plus it had parabens so
you'd get all these info Graphics where
estheticians were just saying Cetaphil
is toxic sludge which it isn't again
clean beauty is BS it is just a
misunderstanding of Toxicology but there
are just a lot of easy reasons to pick
on it and it seemed kind of like they
hadn't updated the formula for a few
decades because it is a really old
school formula lots of people do like it
and I think there was probably a big
outcry when they did finally reformulate
it to this current version now this new
version I think is a bit of a marketing
dream at the moment because it just has
a whole bunch of ingredients that
Everyone likes and nothing that's too
easy to pick on so they've taken out the
SLS and the parabens and they have this
really short ingredients list which I
think a lot of people like because it's
a little bit less intimidating it feels
a bit less stranger danger there are
some trendy actives in this panthenol
and niacinamide so vitamin B5 and B3
which I think are just really easy to
Market there are some nice hydrating
ingredients so glycerin and panto
lactone and yeah it's just a really
inoffensive formula again it is
non-foaming so it's very similar to that
CeraVe hydrating cleanser so I think
this is probably trying to compete with
that I find it really inoffensive it's
fine it's not like a joy to use but it's
really good so I'm going to put it again
in solid Choice all right our next one
is the ordinary hyaluronic acid I think
hyaluronic acid has been trending for
such a long time it's just pushed a lot
in Western skin care it's a humectant
moisturizer that grabs onto water and
keeps your skin hydrated by sort of
trapping water sticking to water and
keeping it on your skin I don't think
most people need a separate hyaluronic
acid product I think the main complaint
that people have about it that I agree
with is that it's just a bit boring as a
humectant there are so many other
ingredients that can do more like
glycerin is in so many things and it's a
really good humectant already there's
the snail lessons which is just a heavy
hitter this is just a bit mess so yeah I
don't hate it but it's just gonna go in
this area where I probably wouldn't
recommend it but if you're using it I'm
not going to like knock it out of your
hand then we have the ordinary's
glycolic acid toner this one I have
mixed feelings on because this is a bit
strong so it says seven percent but it
doesn't really feel like a seven percent
glycolic acid product I think a lot of
people end up over using this and then
burning their skin a lot but I think it
is really good for people who want a
stronger chemical exfoliant and it is
such good value it is a huge bottle I've
actually been using this on other parts
of my body I've been using it under my
arms as a deodorant I know some people
also use it on their scalp to like
exfoliate their scalp so yeah this is a
good product I'm going to say solid
Choice as long as you're using it
properly and you're not yeah drowning
your face in it all right number 15 is
the CeraVe healing ointment this is not
officially available in Australia but I
do like it so back in 2015 the idea of
covering your face in Vaseline overnight
became really popular on Reddit there
was some posts about becoming a slug
which was kind of funny because people
were into snail at the time as well so
yeah that seems to be the origin of the
term slugging although people have been
doing this for a much longer time Tiara
Willis who is an esthetician I think
she's most active on Twitter I think she
came up with the term glazed donut which
is a bit nicer than slugging and yeah
it's to do with using CeraVe healing
ointment as you'd expect the main
ingredient in this is petroleum jelly
which is thick and it's the gold
standard occlusive ingredient so it's
really good at sealing in water into
your skin there's a bunch of other stuff
mixed into this as well so you've got
CeraVe standard ceramides there's also
hyaluronic acid to hydrate and there's a
bunch of other occlusives in this as
well I think they're added there so that
this makes it a bit more spreadable than
your standard petroleum jelly I think
I'm going to shuffle some of my ratings
I'm going to put the glycolic acid tone
up to Holy Grail I actually can't think
of another chemical exfoliant that is
this budget friendly and I think that is
rare enough that it can go under there
and then I'm gonna put the CeraVe
healing ointment into solid choice
because I I personally am not a huge fan
of slugging on my skin it's fine for
other people's skin but I just find it a
bit messy on my pillowcase and yeah I've
got other products that I prefer for
that which is yeah the lorage per se
sticker plus so there are my rankings of
these 15 as you would expect nothing is
not for anyone because these are like
the most popular 15 products on a really
big website I'll put the link to the
full list in the description so you can
check all of that out if you want yeah
let me know what you think of these
products and my rankings was I really
really harshly unfair to like the
ordinary is niacinamide let me know if
you have any ideas for other ranking
videos if you want to nerd out more I
recently did a video where I talked
about my whole approach to skincare and
I will see you next time